[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de economía
aquí en directo a América y para eso nos
acompaña Daniela Blandón la niña de la
buen miércoles para usted bienvenida
Muchas gracias María claro Buenos días
quiero que empecemos con un tema
bastante enredado Y es el techo de la
deuda en Estados Unidos porque ya pasó
el primero de los tres pasos que tiene
que pasar en el congreso Así es María
Clara Pues el primer examen de este
proyecto que lo que hace es quitar el
límite de endeudamiento del país por los
próximos dos años hoy está para la
vigencia de este año están 31,4 billones
de dólares pues ya surtió el trámite el
lunes en el comité de reglas de la
cámara de representantes ahora pasa a
pleno como paso previo a su examen En el
senado y las partes confían en que los
votos están garantizados Todo esto
debería ocurrir antes del próximo lunes
nuestro corresponsal en Washington
Cristóbal Vázquez nos entregó detalles
a pesar de la resistencia de los
conservadores más radicales en el comité
de reglas de la cámara representantes
pasó a plenaria con siete votos a favor
seis en contra el proyecto para levantar
el límite de la deuda que entre otras
cosas pues evita el deporte financiero
de Estados Unidos el 5 de Julio como ya
lo había advertido la secretaria del
tesoro Janet yelen fue una campaña de
mucho cabildeo que tuvo que hacer la
casa blanca y Kevin mccarthy presidente
de la cámara de representantes para que
los republicanos moderados aprobaran
esta esta iniciativa en el comité de
reglas para que este miércoles en
plenaria de la cámara de representantes
se trate de aprobar este proyecto una
vez si es aprobado pasa a senado y de
ahí pasa el escritorio del presidente
Joe biden para que se firme y Estados
Unidos pueda seguir endeudándose hasta
el primero de enero del 2025 y evite
entrar en deut es decir pueda cumplir
sus obligaciones financieras hasta esta
fecha fue una campaña de mucho cabildeo
Joe estuvo Llamando a decenas de
congresistas personalmente para contar
con este apoyo y también lo hizo Kevin
mccarthy tratando de justificar esta
negociación que hizo con la Casa Blanca
a pesar de que los republicanos más
radicales están amenazando con hacer una
moción de censura es decir contratar de
destituir al presidente de la cámara de
representantes Kevin mccarthy Pero hay
esperanzas de que este miércoles pase el
proyecto y Estados Unidos no entre en
default por primera vez en su historia
y de Estados Unidos nos vamos a China
porque elon musk está allí y ha tenido
reuniones de alto nivel Así es pues
llegó a Beijing el martes en su Jet
privado y tras reunirse con el ministro
de relaciones exteriores en primera
instancia en el en la reunión que hizo
un llamado para que las dos principales
economías del mundo que son China y
Estados Unidos no pierdan sus vínculos
económicos hoy el turno fue para el
ministro de comercio después de estos
encuentros con altos funcionarios chinos
el jet del dueño de Twitter spacex y
tesla entre otros partió hacia Shanghai
para visitar la planta del fabricante de
vehículos eléctricos Después de tres
años de ausencia el mercado está muy
pendiente de los anuncios que haga sobre
este en particular ya que es su centro
de producción más grande y enfrenta una
fuerte competencia de los fabricantes
chinos el mercado la expectativa pero la
política llena de polémicas por Esta
visita ya que Estados Unidos tiene unas
tensas relaciones con china yo le
propongo que hablemos ahora de Reino
Unido porque entró en vigencia el primer
tratado o los primeros tratados de libre
comercio desde el brexit pues María
Clara los acuerdos con Australia y Nueva
Zelanda se dan en un contexto en el que
Londres está mirando hacia lindo
Pacífico para suplir lo que ha dejado de
transar con la Unión Europea en los
últimos años a través del brexit estos
pactos comerciales eliminan casi todos
los aranceles a los productos que se
intercambian entre Reino Unido Y estos
dos países pero también entrega mayores
facilidades migratorias entre otros
beneficios Nueva Zelanda cree que se va
a ahorrar unos 22 millones de dólares al
año en aranceles por su parte Reino
Unido Busca Elevar su pib anual y
Australia va a haber productos como vino
miel y nueces entrar al país europeo sin
pagar un solo impuesto Daniela y
volvemos a coincidir usted y yo en las
conversaciones de noticias económicas y
medioambientales esta vez ese cruce se
está viendo en yemen sí y coincidimos
también en color verde muy ambiental
como siempre una embarcación yemení
lleva casi una década varada en el mar
rojo y Naciones Unidas trata de
recuperarla porque se ha convertido en
una bomba medioambiental con una carga
de 1,1 millones de barriles de petróleo
si ocurriera un derrame podría ser
considerado el más grave de este tipo en
la historia Ramiro cuevarberena tiene
los detalles
un barco de apoyo perteneciente a
Naciones Unidas navega por el mar rojo
con una misión iniciar lo más pronto
posible el operativo de salvamiento del
fs o safer una embarcación de
almacenamiento petrolero que posee más
de un millón de barriles de crudo y que
se ha convertido en una bomba
medioambiental tras quedar varado en
durante el año pasado tuvimos varias
reuniones y discusiones con las Naciones
Unidas hubo avances y retrasos a veces
pero Hemos llegado a esto hoy que es la
culminación del trabajo en el período
pasado
en el mar rojo desde 1987 frente al
puerto Rebelde de odeira una de las
principales puertas de entrada para la
ayuda humanitaria del país desde el
estallido del conflicto yemení en 2014
el barco petrolero quedó abandonado sin
recibir mantenimiento el agua ha
deteriorado la estructura generando
peligros de explosión y un accidente
medioambiental sin precedentes el
programa de las Naciones Unidas para el
desarrollo advirtió que un derrame
afectaría 200.000 medios de subsistencia
y comunidades enteras quedarían expuesta
toxinas
creo que esta combinación Nos ha
funcionado muy bien para encontrar una
salida a un problema que ha estado aquí
durante ocho años la gente ha estado
hablando de ello pero sin hacer nada al
respecto este grupo ha podido hacer algo
al respecto creo que tendremos éxito
la ONU estima que la operación comenzará
en 10 días y demorará meses sostienen
que la cantidad de petróleo es cuatro
veces más grande que el derrame de
Alaska en 1989 una de las mayores
catástrofes de este tipo Pues ojalá no
haya derrames de este barco Daniela y
cuéntenos cuál es la cifra del día Bueno
antes de decirle la cifra del día la
invitó a que veamos las siguientes
imágenes
cómo le parece
impresionante de madera lo más
impresionante es que es de madera y lo
van a subastar hasta 200.000 euros
esperan que podrían recaudar tras la
subasta que será hecha el próximo
domingo en Francia de este modelo
citroën Entonces se ve que es el único
de madera en el mundo que está en
perfecto estado de funcionamiento la
carrocería de este modelo original de la
que se llama La Bella los Data de 1955
fue fabricada íntegramente en madera
frutal por el carpintero Michelle
robilla el guardabarros está hecho de
nogal la carrocería de pera y manzana y
las puertas y el maletero están hechos
de madera de cerezo como se puede ver
también en las imágenes pues este que
sale a la venta fue fabricado entre 2011
y 2017 como podemos verlos a la vez un
auto y también una obra de arte la buena
noticia por si está interesada en esta
subasta María Clara es que está
matriculado asegurado y listo para
circular porque tiene todos los permisos
lo compraría sí Ese sí lo compraría Si
tuviera el dinero lo compraría ese Sí
bueno Esperemos entonces que usted
entrega la subasta Daniela Gracias por
toda la información económica y volvemos
con usted dentro de una hora aquí nos
vemos muy juiciosas